PROFESSOR: Hello and welcome
to the help session on
complementation.
Today, we will briefly be
reviewing the concept of
complementation.
And then, we will discuss
complementation with a
non-biological example.
So to begin, complementation is
generally used to determine
if two mutations fall in the
same gene or if they fall in
different genes.
So here, we have two mutants--
mutant one and mutant two.
Both of these have
mutations in the
lysine biogenesis pathway.
So on their own, they cannot
produce lysine.
To determine if these mutations
fall in the same
gene or in different genes, we
need to cross the two mutants
together and examine
their progeny.
If the progeny can grow, this
means that the two mutations
were in different genes,
and thus, they
complement each other.
However, if the progeny cannot
grow, this means that the two
mutations were in the same
gene, and they do not
complement each other.
So now, let me explain
complementation yet another way.
So over here, we have the
knitting pathway.
It's very simple and
straightforward.
In order to knit, you
need two things.
You need both the knitting
needles and you need yarn.
When you have both of these
things together, you can knit
a nice scarf.
So to explain how this is
related to complementation, I
have brought along my friend
Robert to give us a hand.
All right.
So in the first scenario, we're
going to have me with
yarn and Robert with needles.
When I have yarn, I can't knit
by myself, because I am
lacking needles.
This is equivalent to having a
mutation in what we'll call
the gene for needles.
Robert, on the other hand, has
needles, but by himself, he
has no yarn.
So he can't knit.
So alone, neither of us
are able to knit.
However, if we team up and we
work together and we share our
resources, now we have both yarn
and needles, so we can
knit a nice scarf.
All right.
So how about the case of
non-complementation?
If I have needles now, and
Robert also has needles, me by
myself, I cannot knit, because
I have a mutation in that I
have to no yarn.
Robert also has needles and he
also does not have yarn.
So by himself, he can't
knit either.
This time, when we team up and
we try to work together, even
if we share our needles, we
still can't knit, because we
have no yarn.
So this is the case of
non-complementation.
Thanks, Robert.
This concludes the help session
on complementation.
Thanks for joining us.